pretty picture there of Charleston South
Carolina because we're going to begin
this half hour with a conversation with
Republican presidential candidate Nikki
Haley who you might have seen last night
in the CNN Town Hall the former Governor
and U.N Ambassador called China the
number one national security threat and
said the U.S must support Ukraine's
fight against Russia she also talked
about hot button social issues for GOP
voters like gun laws abortion laws and
transgender rights so Ambassador Nikki
Haley it is my pleasure to welcome you
to CBS mornings thank you for getting up
with us this morning you are in Iowa
today where you have been for a very
long time you were the first candidate
to announce and you seemed committed to
visiting every Farm in that state one
thing that voters do when they're
hearing your pitch is imagine you in the
job right now if you were in charge so I
want to start there we had this incident
in the Taiwan Strait yesterday where a
Chinese warship cut in front of an
American Destroyer how should the U.S
respond
well with strength to start with I mean
I think it's not just that you look at
Russia invading Ukraine you look at you
know China on the March you look at Iran
building a bomb you look at North Korea
testing ballistic missiles none of this
would have happened had we not had that
debacle in Afghanistan I mean the idea
that we left Bagram Air Force Base in
the middle of the night without telling
our allies who stood shoulder to
shoulder with us for decades because we
asked them to be there think about what
that told our friends but more
importantly think about what that told
our enemies so now they smell blood in
the water and we're seeing they sense
weakness and they're trying to move
through what we need to do is show
strength we need to let them know what
we expect of them and what we're going
to do about it
do you think military conflict with
China could come in the next 48 years
I think what's important is that we
prevent that and the way you prevent
that is that you have to be strong and
that's why I think it's so important
that Ukraine has to win this war on
Russia because if Ukraine wins this war
it sends a message to China on Taiwan it
sends a message to Iran wanting to build
a bomb and threaten Israel it sends a
message you know to North Korea and all
the other enemies that want to destroy
us if Ukraine loses then Russia is going
to move into Poland in the baltics and
we're looking at World War III and
you're going to see China move into
Taiwan so it's doesn't mean we put money
on the ground doesn't mean we put troops
on the ground but what it means is we
should continue to work with our allies
so that they have the equipment and the
ammunition they need to win
uh Madam Ambassador let's talk about
abortion that is a defining issue for
many voters particularly there in Iowa
last night you declined to take a
position on a federal six-week ban
calling it hypothetical would never pass
as you described it but where would you
draw that line how many weeks at what
point federally
what I've said is that I am
unapologetically pro-life but it's a
very personal issue I'm pro-life because
my husband was adopted I'm pro-life
because I had trouble having my children
and what I think we need to do is
understand everybody has a story I don't
judge people for being pro-choice any
more than I want them to judge me for
being pro-life but if we're going to
have a conversation about a federal ban
let's have an honest one in order to do
a band you'd have to have a majority of
the house 60 Senate votes and a
signature by by President we haven't had
60 pro-life senators in over 100 years
we might have 45. so the reality is
whatever we do on the federal level has
to be consensus so a Republican
president Can't Ban abortions any more
than a Democrat president can ban all
these laws that are happening in the
states so where can we agree we can
agree let's stop late-term abortions
let's make sure that if doctors and
nurses don't believe in abortion they
shouldn't have to perform them let's
encourage more adoptions and make sure
our children children in foster care
feel love let's make sure contraception
is accessible and let's say that if a
woman has an it has an abortion she
shouldn't go to jail or get the death
penalty let's start there and instead of
demonizing the issue let's humanize the
issue
Madam Ambassador another topic driving
conversation today is transgender rights
there was a question last night about
transgender Sports particularly Youth
Sports you took a run at it and I don't
know if it came out exactly as you
intended I want to play that sound and
then have you respond to it let's go
with it
logical boys playing in girls Sports it
is the women's issue of our time
my daughter ran track in high school I
don't even know how I would have that
conversation with her how are we
supposed to get our girls used to the
fact that biological boys are in their
locker rooms and then we wonder why a
third of our teenage girls seriously
contemplated suicide last year we should
be growing strong girls confident girls
so Madam Ambassador I wanted you to
clarify if you could the connection uh
there to teen suicide
well I mean first of all when girls are
seeing multiple I talked to a senior
high school girl in New Hampshire a
couple weeks ago and she said in every
single classroom they're talking about
transgenderism and she said I feel like
I'm walking on eggshells because we
don't know what we can say and what we
can't girls need to feel confident in
their own skin they need to be able to
do that when you see someone like Dylan
Mulvaney mocking women when you see the
fact that they're now having to go and
have biological Boys in their locker
rooms that's not good for teenage girls
that's not something they need to be
focused on it's not that we don't
understand and and appreciate the
challenges of someone who's transgender
but why are you putting that on
everybody else let the girls have their
own locker room let the girls have their
own sports that was the whole point of
Title IX don't go and push you know the
challenges of a small minority onto the
majority of our girls that's not they
don't deserve that
Madam Ambassador another question is
what care should be on the table when a
12 year old child in this country
assigned female at Birth says actually I
feel more comfortable living as a boy
what should the law allow the response
to be
well I think the law should stay out of
it and I think parents should handle it
this is a job for the parents to handle
and then when that child becomes 18 if
they want to make more of a permanent
change they can do that but I think up
until then we see with our teenage kids
they go through a lot during puberty
they go through a lot of confusion they
go through a lot of anxiety they go
through a lot of pressures we should
support them the whole way through but
we don't need to go and enforce
something in schools we don't need
schools sitting there hiding from the
parents what gender pronoun they're
using we don't need to have those
conversations in schools those are
conversations that should be had at home
all right Nikki Haley first female
governor of South Carolina hoping to be
the first female president of the United
States thank you very much
thanks go to nikkihaley.com